part two of my co-workers crazy breakup  story those of you who did not see part  one this is what my ex-girlfriend did to  my bedroom i walk in you know my first  thought is oh my god somebody robbed us  somebody broke in and stole all my stuff  until i saw the condom nailed to the  wall and her handwriting written all  over my walls i i knew what happened all  the cops right away and when they showed  up i realized there was chocolate milk  poured all over my mattress in bed did  not end up pressing charges the cops did  file a police report  and i think they gave her a small ticket  as well so peter i'm assuming you never  talked to this [ __ ] again right  well  you know she was a dancer so  i mean